if you could play an instrument if you
could be in a band called a guitar slap
by the baby it's piano piano piano be
cool I feel like if I could just get on
that guitar and do something like Dave
Matthews yeah didn't satellite in my not
a bad deal out of that whose are you
Dave Matthews fan how can you not be a
little bit god I thought you had a hate
on us no come on he's got a turn yeah do
that again that was good not good not
that good usually at first I know that
it was not bad dude I love David again I
want to hear it again you've been
listening man I got to hear it let me
have it chicken mine he's so good just a
second with a Wi-Fi oh it's down yeah
you fix you you could do a cover of Dave
Matthews gene can't you I could probably
do pretty much I'd say cry anything and
we do it oh yeah he's very good yeah oh
you like out on this kick with him
because he was on Howard Stern yeah
that's like I still love Dave Matthews
so I've been going down this whole
catalogue I celebrate all his catalog
here's the thing if you don't like Dave
Matthews just I understand but please
look it put yourself in a position where
you've been hearing a lot of music and
then you he comes along he's unique he's
got a very unique voice and sound so
just the bump bump bump bump bump on yes
teacher when he was growing up used to
make him warm up with a with this you
know I was going his teachers to make
him warm up so he went into it the
studio and told his he was doing his
bands like oh we could do something with
that and then he's surrounded by like
musical geniuses so they're like oh
let's try this and then he starts
writing lyrics
what a [ __ ] Jam he's not American you
know that he's not South South African
he is yep SATs at yeah in high school as
that I mean we I mean that's pretty good
dick sucks like Dave Matthews he's not
gay okay man
is he really he's marrying know what
that's fine buddy hey what's my age well
over followers called chin Dave have
slaves Dave Schley I'm a Dave slave now
take it easy dude fact that now listen
I'm a Dave life if you know what that
entail
bro I'm a Dave flip but no date a friend
are you going cuz I want a slave brave
dad Brendan Brendan hi be brave be brave
Brennan listen me buddy his slave cuz
he's gonna make you do some stuffy gay
he's gay dude if he plays that satin
pants off and you're gonna have to end
up whatever dude I'm a Dave slave he had
a girlfriend dude she's not okay kiss
I'm talking I'm in the Sun god damn he's
been married like seven bothers me about
that [ __ ] rumor anyway this is what
this is where I got that from ready cuz
in the back of my mind I remember
somebody saying oh I have a friend hit
on and now my guys gay alright this Dave
Matthews getting up that's a rumor
everybody though yeah like Nate let's go
becoming 10 things surprising to you
know really know why have you watched
him before yeah I said never gets tired
but I just thought fighting somebody
like Robbie Lawler who I thought looked
amazing amazing and physically looked
amazing yeah yeah um Nicole was just
it's just a bad matchup for Robbie come
out of the same camp too used to they're
at different camp oh they are now yeah
okay I was just so good man so good
inverse kymaro's means the move they
don't like each other
great matchup two similar stealth both
both wrestlers both you know both cardio
machines yeah that's the fight what do
you think oh I do I pray give kymaro the
slight advantage even though he said he
had surgery at that hernia thing he had
something else going on so if he's ready
to go though like if it is right level a
low well no let's it Colby's actually
more decorated wrestler oh yeah he was
all-american pack pac-12 Oregon State
like cope with Amar's Christ also does
cardio with [ __ ] Cameron Haynes
though good God
yeah good God what about who's better
striker tomorrow here's more power but
Colby strikings pretty [ __ ] good too
but tomorrow has more power neither ones
like it knockout artist though yeah
Busey who gets taken down though ah
that's gonna be so do you guys remember
a story a while back about this little
boy taking his grandpa's car to go to a
liquor store nearby to get snack
yeah made it alright right like he
[ __ ] up some stuff but yeah like a
mailbox yeah but he made it not bad yeah
so a little ten-year-old girl tried to
do the same thing with her mom's car to
go to McDonald's the only thing is that
she ended up getting lost and she tried
to make a turn in a car hit hurt luckily
nobody was hurt she got like a couple of
bruises but she's okay so apparently
there's just an influx of kids stealing
cars now I wonder why just to go get
snacks I mean just ask the parent to get
some goddamn snacks and she wasn't at
Tahoe - yeah that's a good car but
that's cardigans yakun true but the
little girl is okay she never made it to
McDonald's though I mean I couldn't go
nowhere without me knowing sometimes
don't pretend no you never know never
know dude I think your kid's gonna be
real big at ten so I think he is the
other day since no Drive he's gonna come
and start bullying me at tenth
I'll bully you right now they're already
my size what else you got
sorry got [ __ ] he's already got traps
for real no I'd love to do it I'd stare
at his tattoos and there's like numbers
with bullets next to them I assume what
they offer
what didn't he went down so hard you
know she [ __ ] remind me right now and
it's a great one is when I was a
contractor I was in Santa Barbara born
and raised there moved back after the
military and then there was this [ __ ]
chick that I was kind of dating for a
while yeah and big tits hey hey
well I forget I think I'm we're gonna
ask man to be honest let him tell us -
uh sorry keep going though but I'm
talking about the romanization of kind
of veterans sometimes and so I'm I get a
call from my contracting office to go in
this deployments super boring ass
deployment it was in a place that was
super permissive but hey it was gonna be
fun I tell this chick that I'm dating
hey I got it I gotta [ __ ] go in like
two days and she's like yeah you have to
go white white were you going I can't
talk about it
Americans can't talk America needs me so
I bounced three [ __ ] days later bin
Laden gets killed the message I got from
that girl I guarantee she masturbated
every single night yes she wrote me
she's like I know now USA why you had to
leave you in the service for your cut
thank you that's all I have to in and
out and I was like do I say I'm not
Sealand I definitely didn't kill no miss
Lisa [ __ ] when I go you're welcome yeah
like thank you for my service because
I'm gonna service you in there look at
the Comedy Store this dude was passing
counterfeit bills this giant guy grabs
him throws him on the ground put some
over goes to arrest him he said he's ID
like I'm off-duty cop bouncer at the
[ __ ] at the saddle ranch
yeah and he's kidding a hard time I
gotta give me your [ __ ] hands he says
why does a Rath and they see me what
blood long story short they arrest the
guy I left when the cops came this guy
didn't want to get sued so he goes yeah
the guy from MADtv Bryan Callen the
comic was the one who got him put tied
him up and stuff like that cuz he put so
all the comics were like Bryan did you
do karate thing on this giant do you
know the story yeah and I came back hell
of a [ __ ] killer dude I swear I go
dude what the [ __ ] that we heard you did
this jujitsu [ __ ] on this giant black
hood who's passing counterfeit bills had
him on the ground and I would and this
is what I did I went like this I go yeah
ask me what I do in the military ask me
what would you do the military this and
that he asked me if I ever took a life
amen
you ever kill anybody over there never
stopped to look brother doing my job
ya know it's just a job to me me now ask
me seriously what did you do in the
military seriously bro would you do over
there you wake up for every morning yeah
you're welcome
that's bear oh [ __ ] I wouldn't like that
was straight your welcome for my service
yeah yeah
thank you for my service that's okay you
can say it's a great title shape for
buds you know so just Tim Kenny I was
talking about how I want to be
waterboarded I always make the joke and
someone sent it to him you know Tim's on
my buddy and I was in Austin and he
tweet out shop where he heard you were
looking to get waterboarded me my boys
are out and you know I go i but haha
crazy he goes no for reals just send me
an address cuz I was in town doing
comedy he's like send me a dress we'll
make it happen we can film and with it I
was like oh well no Tim I I wanted to
try it
he waterboarded themselves you see that
yeah I love Tim he's a crazy bastard
talk about a dangerous person another
guy yeah you kind of lose every
with him we talked about another guy
who's kicking ass outside of the
military yeah man of course he is super
awesome he did that we were at up it on
it I'm an Arby's place and we walked I
walked in with my wife and he looked he
looked at my wife it was like man you're
really gorgeous in real life some people
don't look that good in real life and I
was like I will shoot oh that's like man
that's just hard either way it's gonna
be shitty he beat my ass he's remarkably
well like he's just he's such a good
dude he's just a nice it's got a great
so honey [ __ ] dude and at the same
time he's he's the you tempt you do a
podcast and take over the world
yes there's both funny man that's true
appreciate it you guys are both that
would be a good podcast out what the
best podcast ever yeah and I don't even
podcast anymore so you know yes that all
anymore he's so why not also why is he
so shredded I don't know all right
there's a few people when everyone goes
everyone's on peds and like I hear you
but him no cuz he's all ready for a UFC
I think if they were like hey you got a
you know a title fight he would jump
right back in and do it I know he's
somewhat retired but he's such a [ __ ]
beast look it's so cheesy so me holding
that your dad this whole entire episode
has us been man lusting over
special-operations dudes we went through
the seals now rod Tim Kennedy we
apologize sorry with the Wolves dude let
me run with you guys sure let me see
your best wolf howl watch my ready okay
what's here
that's like Celine Dion animal
you can hold this manner or while
performing singing lessons geez now you
[ __ ] try that cuz that's not a wolf
sky be more like it a little that's a
[ __ ] coyote that ain't a [ __ ] wolf
Chad I get my dog to give me a [ __ ]
wolf howl man no not a wolf but ok me a
dog barks let's he's got their dog oh no
you have like all dog yeah yeah a small
dog man that's still a dog see you wolf
howl bro stop see you wolf oh come on
his was good
yours is very something very strange
miss God did very strange is long